June 24 2003 storm chaser Tim Samaras is
in tornado alley looking for trouble
this thing turned into a big gust front
his goal to place as many scientific
probes as possible directly in the path
of a giant twister the trick do it
without getting killed the perfect
conditions are forming near a tiny
hamlet called Manchester
[Music]
Tim and his teammates drive towards a
massive thundercloud about seven miles
out a funnel starts taking shape
he tries to get closer but no roads need
in the right direction
this is the
immediately
the way to again riding
the outraces the tornado forty miles we
took the road heading east basically
going right into the path of the tornado
one probe down five to go
the chasers estimate it's at least an f4
tornado with winds over 200 miles an
hour a twister this fierce can level a
well-built house and turn a mobile home
into a missile
Tim's probes will record wind speed
barometric pressure and other data if
the tornado sweeps directly overhead the
more he deploys the better the odds
take it
didn't I
but playing chicken with a twister is a
dangerous game
the tornado shreds a nearby farmhouse a
reminder of what 200 mile an hour winds
can do still Tim is determined to deploy
the last of his six probes
he was saying that but I was thinking
something else I was already out of the
car I got the probe I put it on the
ground I jumped in my deployed 5 to 7
seconds then suddenly the tornado turns
on them
twisters can accelerate at speeds of 70
miles an hour this one is only 100 yards
away and bearing down fast if it catches
up
it'll fling their van through the air
then crush it like a tin can
the driver puts the pedal to the metal
but the tornado seems to be gained the
twister chases the van down the road
then at the very last second veers away
and loses steam they escape unharmed
you